there's like two guys in the space who
work definitely work harder than i do
how many shows do you do a week adam i
mean my brother talked about this
because i
i was complaining about i did like five
shows or something like that in a week
and he's like dude you ever seen how
many adam does
well i i haven't figured it out well but
i got i do my show
every day so that that would be five and
then
how long does that show uh like two
hours there you go and then i do
me and dr drew so that would be three
more so
now we're at eight and then i do a car
cast nine
and then i do a home improvement one ten
and then i do
nobody who talks who's better at talking
oh and then i do uh me and mark garrigus
do like uh
legal oh really so i guess uh we're at
eleven
motivational podcast i guess uh 12
and then yeah probably 15 or something
how insane is that dude that's [ __ ]
crazy
yeah it's weird what drives you what you
just have things to say and you're just
interested in that
you know i you know i a couple things
like
first things first like people always go
oh you work so much i go
is this work is it because what we're
doing now work i mean
i know what work is you know every you
know work people [ __ ]
[ __ ] work meant you got on the roof
or under the building
you know like work was like getting
dirty
work was moving stuff you know i grew up
with
work really meaning like something
tactile
and physical like work meant you got
paid by the hour
and you had to move [ __ ] or spread [ __ ]
yeah or
rip [ __ ] up and throw it down not gonna
work with your face right you're like
working with your face and i was like i
when is talking talking so to me
my mentality was kind of like you work
all day
for me it was construction and then at
night
maybe you go out with a couple of
friends and you have a beer
and you do this so i had it so
ingrained in me that this isn't work
for such a long period of time that when
i started doing this i never
looked at his work and i was always
curious like
you know i started 12 and a half years
ago you know and i'd say to like
other you know no one did a podcast but
everyone kind of come in
you know like sarah silverman or
something like that and i go you should
do a podcast i go uh how
often i go like every day and they go oh
come on i'm not going to do that
it's like right do what she's doing
yeah you sit around you talk yeah i mean
how many comedians struck up a podcast
during this pandemic well he was doing
radio 26 years ago i i met you 26 years
ago when i did
uh love line or dr drew when we were
doing when i was on mad tv we the cast
came on
that's right and then i remember i
remember it was funny because i remember
you surprising me with how witty you
were and i was like this [ __ ] dude's
turning everything into funny
and even you were doing it back then i
told you you're the you're i've never
seen anybody do
i've never seen anybody do what adam did
which was get up on stage
in front of a packed house at brea and
they were throwing out suggestions like
topics
and he would go on roll with it he would
roll with it but do a fully formed bit
basically and he did that for an hour
i watched it and i came up to him i
didn't even i didn't know you that well
i'd guessed it on and i go you're the
best in the world at
coming up with improvising on on uh
that's my favorite
compliment um you are i've ever received
and
and uh i always appreciate when you say
that no but i mean that that's just from
the
more than ten thousand hours how many
how many how many hours you've spoken a
million hours
probably one podcasting yeah you did ten
thousand last week yeah yeah yeah yeah
ten thousand oh yeah you're a
grandmaster millions of thousands
you did growlings right yeah i did
growlings i
i you know i don't people have this sort
of
weird cartoon version of me which is
like
i'm just some thug that came off the
construction site like
a nail kind of knuckle dragon just kind
of blue-collar douchey guy who has some
sort of homespun
witticism like they look at me as like a
like sort of comedy savant
but it's like but but you know kind of
like rain man
with comedy yeah but the reality is
i was at the groundlings when i was like
21 22
i went all the way through the
groundlings after the groundlings were
done with me um because i didn't make it
into being a groundling i went
off and started or helped start a group
called the acme theater
oh wow i didn't know you helped start
that i was at the acme theater
two or three names before it became acme
like we were like the two roads players
and the whatever
i you know answering an ad and like the
back of the drama log that my
girlfriend found and then i built the
acme theater that was on
lankershim which is now turned into
something else in noho
back when they're trying to get like
noho off the ground
so i had i i had this
real training in
in improvisational comedy but
no everyone thought i just was a
construction guy who was like funny
you know kind of off the cuff but when i
got
into radio and the reason i i
progressed so quickly as soon as i got
into radio is because i had
all this training and and i knew how to
use
the training i knew you know yes and not
only that but like i knew all do you
know about the ground like this yes
yeah improvisation no i'm saying the the
but the it's so intense for sure
i mean right the training at the ground
links is [ __ ] intense you have to
audition just to take a class
you gotta go through like to get to the
final like saturday night it's happening
oh they're working
so hard saturday night live yeah i
watched taren kill him doing it yeah
yeah he went through it and it was like
the amount of work that went into coming
up with characters fully formed
in situations because there's the ground
links here and then what was is the
groundlings two in chicago we're like
i mean there's a bunch of them it's all
there's a few big boys
it's great training though it's great
training great and and what they
do you know it's weird because it's
invisible
and you don't get a certificate so
people you know when you're weld
no you can well right but there's no
degree like no one knows who's been
through it or hasn't
but they're they're definite rules
they're definite
techniques you know they're pretty
brutal
like i took my first groundling class
i don't know i was probably like 20 22
23.
i was just making nine bucks an hour
doing
construction i didn't have insurance for
my truck
and i still gave the ground links like
250 bucks
and when we're done with my first like
beginners course
they were like you're funny but you
can't act for [ __ ] like you don't know
which way to stand you don't know what
you know
you know with your hands i had all these
all the people there were like college
people who did
drama and high school and stuff and i i
played sports and then i got into
construction i didn't know so they'd be
like
we had to move a little further upstage
no no not downstage
upstage i mean i don't know went up yeah
stages and they go just stage left
and i'd start moving like out the other
direction no and i'd pull my dick out
you're funny you don't know how to act
you don't know anything and i was like
all right
they go go take an acting class and
once you complete your acting class then
we'll let you move up
to to intermediate and and i've seen
them cut like i have had classes with
14 people in it and they told 12 of them
to
like yeah to your point i think a lot of
people be surprised what guys came out
of the groundlings like you know doc
shepard did it forever yeah there's a
still hear guys talk about it and then
like yeah i want to do like groundlings
in hollywood like
[ __ ] shepherd was there too pharaoh i
mean
so many great people came out of there
and so many people who are working who
did who like you said trained
and didn't make it but i didn't make it
but you know still crushed
but um what did you see did any of you
guys see one movie in the oscars
what do you think of hollywood oh no i i
i i saw uh the
one you told me to watch what no i did
see santa man
but what's the one with the girl who
gets the revenge oh oh
promising promise young promising lady
yeah i saw that one
yeah good ending what do you what do you
think of uh like do you think hollywood
is
i feel like nobody's talking about that
remember when a movie would tran a movie
star would do a movie we'd all be
talking about it well to be fair
actually i talked to our boy about this
who's high up there in that hollywood
world
and i was making fun of the oscars and
he goes bret and stop stops up he goes
everyone's
regurgitating the same perspective
because you got to realize
this granted they are pushing this
agenda but it's also
the studios and the main actors they're
not working dude
because because the studio is shut down
so the big boys they're not out right
now
and also they know they can't be in
theaters where they're making their nut
so they're chilling man it's like he
goes
it's like you don't see joe coy and dave
chappelle and these guys dave who did
but
you don't see them torn around right now
or you don't see musicians dropping
their biggest album because they can't
tour
so the big dogs are just waiting in the
shadows waiting for this [ __ ] to open up
and then you'll start it's just two
years because it's a two year break
they're not making the same because he's
like the narrative you keep pushing i
get it and
yes they're doing that thing but the big
boys aren't in it for a reason
well movies will be back movies will be
back how about that when i get off stage
at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this front
of a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song
so this colt brennan was my roommate for
a little bit university of colorado he's
a redshirt
freshman and we would drive together in
the freezing
weather and university of colorado
during they called
dirty dozens and there's the way